hey everybody welcome back to a my city
in this episode we're working on the
downtown of the city and also some
canals around it that also formed the
borders of the artificial islands that
will make up the city in the future and
do a bunch more detailing around the
area specifically with the new prop
snapping mod which I think is going to
be quite a game-changer it actually
allows you to snap props to buildings
and do all kinds of stuff with that so
let's get started now one of the first
few things that I wanted to do in this
episode is get in all of the buildings
in the downtown that will really shape
the way that it will look now what I
wanted to do with this downtown is
actually give it a bit like slightly
that American sort of look to it so
really have one central tower which is
the most unique and the tallest out of
the bunch and have some slightly lower
towers around it that build up towards
the central tallest tower but actually
wanted to have a bit of a twist to it as
well since I didn't want to make it as
strictly american-style downtown and I
also wanted to keep the downtown quite
small actually I wanted to disperse and
scattered the high-rises in the city a
little bit more instead of concentrating
them in one place so while this is the
place where the tallest building of the
city is I will have a bunch of different
clusters around the city kind of in a
sense similar to how Rotterdam has
certain zones for instance where there
isn't really one place where the entire
skyline is built but rather you've got a
couple of small clusters of high-rise
that I sort of really planned to fit
together instead of one very large
building up cluster so that's what I'm
kind of going for there just a couple of
high-rise buildings and the rest is just
going to be some mid rise building that
builds up around it in a kind of
symmetrical way to build this very
central plaza which is probably the most
important part of the downtown right in
the middle of all these skyscrapers and
we're gonna have a canal around that in
the future as well I just wanted to make
sure that everything sort of comes
together around
downtown so we have the most important
road going on the side here we also have
the Central Station and we're going to
have the canal as well and hopefully
that's all going to fit together with
the buildings of the downtown not to her
tightly squished in between all that so
Otto I kind of sorted out the rails for
a little bit there I actually had the
rail in the middle of the road for quite
a while but in the end I decided it
might just look a little bit better if I
have the rail on the side of it it's
also a little bit easier with the
station and I don't really have to worry
about making this city as compact as I
can I just wanted to keep it quite dense
which is why I originally thought I
could have the real over the middle of
the road but it ended up just looking a
bit too claustrophobic and dense so
that's on the side and we can add a
bunch of very small parks and planters
around the rail so that's pretty nice as
well
it's going to look pretty good hopefully
by the end of this episode and I'm
already starting to kind of get into
that at this point just like the first
part of the city has a lot of these
ground decals to give color to the
ground and but a lot of foliage into it
I also wanted to make sure that every
space especially alongside these very
main roads would be decorated quite well
with a lot of foliage
I especially figured that here since
this is a very important and busy road
for traffic as well as for other trains
so I wanted to keep the buildings
further apart from the road here which
is why there's this very wide sidewalk
with these planters in the middle we
should hopefully cancel out the noise
pollution a little bit and make this at
least a slightly nicer place to live
them right next to a very busy road and
kind of be the screen buffer between the
road and the buildings if you will and
it just looks nice and quite happy
actually with how this turned out I
didn't want to put grass down there just
because it's underneath the railroad
there's no way that you could keep up
grass but there were also some other
concerns in a few comments that I got
lost video about maybe placing too much
foliage in the city because in the end
this is a desert city and much of the
foliage that you'd be placing over here
you know would probably have to come
from this Ellen ating water because
you're in a desert and there's barely
any rainfall and no rivers in Bahrain
well I'm not too concerned about that I
don't have too much foliage in this city
and I want to keep it quite low on the
amount of the grass that I have on the
surface but then again I do wanna fill
it with as much foliage as I can I kind
of feel like it's just about okay to do
that because I planned the city to be on
the west coast of Bahrain which is
actually somewhat green it's not that
green but there is actually I found this
on Wikipedia it's not too much like
background research but there's actually
an aquifer underneath Bahrain which is
slightly salty but it's still usable and
which it actually takes a lot of natural
water from so while there aren't any
rivers there is actually some ground
water that has been used for centuries
for irrigation and for any kind of
farming especially on the west coast of
Bahrain which is pretty interesting it's
not at all a 100 percent sandy desert
and I feel like it's somewhat ok to add
a little foliage around here and mostly
it just makes the livability of the city
a lot better as well so really wherever
I can wherever there are these very
wide-open boulevards or plazas I want to
add a lot of foliage same goes for the
plaza over here where I am totally kind
of behind here I went this is basically
the plaza that I was talking about
earlier on which is really the central
plaza of the downtown here now this is
strictly speaking the downtown when it
comes to the high-rise but it's not
really the part of the city that I
planned to be like the the recreational
center of life in the city that is
definitely on the other side of the
train track and closer to the water this
is more like the business center really
the central business district of the
city so it's not really as cozy not as
many different shops but more high-rises
and offices and that kind of stuff
though it is still quite mixed I didn't
want to separate it too much and create
a downtown which is completely dead so
there will be a couple of facades with
shop
and there is definitely some residential
towers in there as well but it's
probably the most business seat part of
the entire city now with all of the
ground decals and the foliage detailing
done which I'm actually really happy
with how their little fountain with the
the path decorations turned out I kind
of was hoping to be able to do a little
bit more with the decorations of paths
when it comes to patterns on paths with
bricks and colors and that kind of stuff
it's quite simple and it's not really
one of the first things that you think
about in the city but I'm actually a
complete sucker for good pavements and I
think actually they contribute quite a
lot to a city being a nice city to live
in and I just wanted to get as many
colorful pavements instead of just empty
concrete everywhere in the city where I
could and if you can get some sweet
patterns into that that's just extra
cool I suppose but what I'm doing here
might look kind of strange with exactly
measuring out all of the distances
between these different paths but what I
wanted to do here is start work on the
first canal and it's not really a canal
since it's just kind of going to be the
divider between the different artificial
islands of the city more about that in a
minute
but I wanted to have this right here as
a kind of way to mark off the central
zone of the city and sort of be the
border between the central island and
the more outer islands of the city so
yeah these will all be artificial
islands what you're seeing right now
outside the desert is or outside the
city is all desert and pretty much just
empty sand and the reason that it's just
completely empty is that lbc at some
point in future I just didn't want to
have to mess around with making the
artificial islands I just feel that it's
easier to already have the scent out
there and once the actual shape of the
city is done start carving away the sand
and let the sea retreat and let the
islands really form instead of having to
see and trying to make islands out of
that from a gameplay perspective I just
think the letter
would have been a little bit harder but
yeah just imagine that a lot of the
sandy playing that you see outside the
city right now which by the way is a way
to light texture of sand strike toys
they left me a comment about this
actually and recommend it to look into
it I have been trying to for a few hours
get some very good textures of sand but
so far either they were too dark or too
light and I'm still kind of messing with
that a little bit but it will see
different sand in the future that's a
little bit more grayish and a little bit
darker because this is very bright but
anyway these will all be Islands in the
future that's really the most important
part about it I'm not sure if I'm going
to make it a very like interesting shape
like the palm islands in Dubai just
because it's that kind of thing is a
very like top-down kind of way to make a
city and I'm not really a big fan of
that like if you're in the city itself
you don't really see the city being in
the shape of a palm tree it's just kind
of interesting from a satellite view and
I'm not really sure if I'm gonna really
make the shape very interesting for the
city but it'll be something at least
it's not going to be a random square I
definitely want to do something with it
the current idea that I have actually is
to give the city that the shape of a
desert flower but that's very far in the
future when the entire shape is all done
anyway one of the reasons that I also
wanted to get this canal here is that
having a waterfall in the middle of the
city is just a great way to make it a
bit nicer to be around kind of like the
canals in Amsterdam or Venice I wanted
to have something over here so that the
downtown opens up a little bit that you
have more of an opportunity to see the
skyscrapers around there and actually
have some nice places where you can sit
and eat and have a nice view over a bit
of water just basically make the city
look a bit more livable then without any
canals between it having interaction
with the water is pretty important for
me and they seemed like a very good
place to have the first canal
so I was struggling a little bit with
these cookies every now and then I was
figuring for quite a while instead of
keys I could actually use some of the
walls that are in the workshop that you
can just place but now I can just use
the keys and put props on top of that
and make my own planters and that way
not have to worry about any pre given
details on workshop items and be able to
fully customize it and put some awesome
palm trees on these keys so that's what
I'm going for in the end which will be a
little bit more work and especially a
struggle every now and then with the
keys but with the movie tool it's
actually really easy to get these keys
and get the exact height that you need
to work out the bridges as well and the
movie tour has been one of the biggest
game changes lately and I'm a really big
fan of it and I'm just finishing the
busway at this point very quickly I
don't have this part of the city become
very um dense with cars since this side
of the plaza to is mostly focused on
pedestrians and being this area where
you can mostly walk around but I didn't
want to have the bus lane in the middle
there since this is kind of a dead
corner when it comes to the light rail
system and it seems like a good place to
have the bus now we're getting into
roadworks for a little bit struggling
with some of these roads because I
wanted to have a connection to the
roundabout that actually looks good and
would actually be a quite functional but
the transition from the Avenue to the
two separate roads was kind of a
struggle every now and then but I
figured it out in the end and the reason
that I wanted to make this roundabout in
the first place that sounded very
Canadian I've no idea where that came
from but the reason why I wanted to make
this roundabout in the first place is
that this is going to be quite an
important connection right now the
connection from the city into the rest
of the world and the other way around is
on the other side on that very small
roundabout but I actually hope to get a
highway connection into this roundabout
right here because this is also the side
of the city where the airport is going
to be
and so this roundabout is really gonna
be the the entry into the city hence why
it's quite a big roundabout and connects
to some of the biggest avenues on the
side here and what's quite an important
thing that I wanted to get in just
around the corner of the downtown
section here and started working on that
for a little bit also this is where the
Canal is gonna turn back around the
other side because the very basic makeup
of this city is that we have the one
large island in the middle which is the
current downtown island and then around
five sides we have five large different
islands and there will be smaller
islands around that as well and all
kinds of different shapes but that's the
very basic premise it is really like a
desert flower we have the center and
five parts around that you could say
it's maybe the five pillars of Islam or
whatever but that's not really the idea
it's just it just looks good
that's why I figured after a couple of
tries of figuring out how I wanted to
layout stuff that's where we're going in
the future and that's also why I am
making these canals right now now much
of the work regarding the planning is
done at this point so it's time to move
into a little bit more detailing and
first off I wanted to do the buildings
over here because they're kind of the
gateway into the downtown we have the
two towers with a bunch of appointment
books and also some shops on the side
there they're technically offices but
gonna make those into shops but that's
going to come in a little bit but are
basically they're kind of the entry into
the downtown on the other side of the
Avenue there it's just going to connect
to another part of the city and two more
suburb ish but really not suburbs part
of the city just not as dense as the
downtown that's really yeah kind of the
gateway into the center of the city here
and a nice little waterfront which is
very Amsterdam ish it's a little bit
actually as well like Dr Omaha Rock
which is this project that Bahrain
actually has of artificial islands where
they're making a new part of a large
city which actually I found very
interesting it's not
- solely sustainable city but actually
found a very interesting how they're
actually looking into social dimensions
as well for the city but mostly it's one
that has a lot of interaction with water
and a lot of these areas with water
fronts and that kind of stuff and
Bahrain at this point has more
artificial islands than real islands so
it's just it kind of just fits into the
country I suppose I'm no expert on the
country but I just figured it would be a
good way to experiment with a plan city
for a little bit also very quick note
now that I'm looking at these first
lanes at this point the entire traffic
system is something that aesthetically
I'll probably want to look into in the
future because yeah there are a couple
of problems that a lot of people
commented about and that I do recognize
one of them being the fact that the bus
lanes are red and have black crossings I
wish they didn't do this but yeah this
is no way to do anything about that and
the shade of red is a little bit
questionable at best I do as well the
thing is just I wanted to use bus routes
because I figured that would keep most
of the cars out of the the bus ways but
little did I know that the sims in the
game don't give a [ __ ] and they're still
using them anyway and others cars going
over my basketball courts and there's
cars going over all of the concrete and
going over every place where I didn't
even want to have cars and that's kind
of a problem and I might look into that
with traffic manager so yeah when it
comes to the bus lanes I might stop cars
from going there I might change it into
regular roads and I stop cars from going
there but leave the buses on it and when
it comes to the concrete paths I'll see
where I can sort out the cars and fix
that stuff I'm just not really gonna do
that yet since I want the entire area to
be finished before I go and tweak the
gameplay related things first kind of
want to get the aesthetics part of the
story done also one thing to note about
this is that the population as you can
tell is like 20,000 which is which is
pretty good but it's not really
realistic I actually since I imported
most of these buildings into Rico myself
and for a lot of these skyscrapers I
counted a couple hundred inhabitants
which is actually fairly reasonable but
for some of the mid rise buildings I
counted a couple hundred as well and I
should not have done that the population
is off the charts and should definitely
a bit lower so the entire amount of
people driving around in cars is
disproportionate to the size of the city
at this point as well I think it would
be a bit lower yeah it's actually going
down in-game now not sure what's
happening though there are a couple of
death waves every now and then but um
yeah I'm probably going to look at that
as well because much of this even though
this is already a pretty sizable city
much of this is also going to be for
like tourists realistically or offices
or commercial purposes so I'm not sure
how realistic the number 20,000 really
is at this point anyway back to how
everything is shaping up over here
because I wanted to get back into the
small buildings which I built on the
Gateway just now I think that's one of
the best things that the prop snapping
mod can actually achieve the fact that
you can snap advertisements and
billboards the buildings means that you
can kind of assign a certain meaning to
a building for instance I wanted to use
those office blocks because I really
like the way that they look and just
like the original model of the game but
there are office blocks and they don't
have any kind of text on them and
nothing that would make them inviting
like put them in a city and it's just
add and block with like no good opening
it's not very open it's very like closed
in on itself kind of building and I
think using these lot of these
billboards and these name signs you can
actually make a building look like
something that it's not originally so
you can take the signs of a restaurant
and the billboards of a restaurant slip
them onto the building and make it look
lot more alive make it look a lot more
like it's part of an active part of a
city where you can hang out and go into
restaurants and bars and that kind of
stuff
I just like that because many of these
buildings don't have that and that lack
of names and billboards just makes the
city look a little bit more dead I
actually had it on some of the
skyscrapers as well what do you see very
often in real life skyscrapers of course
since they're kind of the way of a
company to say my dick is bigger than
yours you always have the name tag or
the logo of a company on the top of the
skyscraper which you don't really have
in the game but there's usually this
place on a building where you can still
put a logo so if I actually think is
very fun is to just add these different
in-game logo boards to slap them on the
top of skyscrapers kind of make them
look as if they're really part of this
one company be it's the fictional
newspaper of City skylines or some kind
of other company it's just a little very
small extra touch of realism that I like
way too much for the reason that it's
just a little bit more immersive than
have all of these buildings be
completely signless and pretty
dead-looking
it's also pretty cool way to make a kind
of what's it called again a Time Square
kind of idea or Piccadilly Circus though
I don't want to mess around too much
with that kind of idiots you can really
make places come alive and be a lot more
interesting by using all of these
billboards and names anyway like the
topic I am way behind the video all the
time the last thing that I wanted to do
here is add the scenery around the
houses here and make this large
Boulevard come to life you can really
see like how white the sidewalks over
here since I wanted the buildings to be
quite far away from the buildings but
hopefully with some of these open spaces
with a lot of green space and some of
the sidewalks and detailing around here
that's that's kind of like a bridged
very large distance between the
buildings I'm quite happy with how the
very large Avenue in the middle over
here turn out it doesn't feel too large
I feel but it's also not too crammed
it's not like the building's sit right
in the middle of the light rail so I'm
quite happy with this very important
main sort of traffic
Avenue and that'll be more or less it
for this episode in the next episode I'm
gonna finish off some of the bits and
bobs of the downtown because while the
downtown itself is definitely finished
at this point I've only really finished
one side of the canal here and I
definitely need to finish the other side
of the canal as well I don't really have
a place where the taxis can stand in the
Central Station and I might even add
another place where buses can hook up
that can go to the other side of the
city or the airport basically turn the
other side of the station which is now
still a desert into a bit of a traffic
hub as well without making it too open
and too much of a concrete field I'm not
sure how I'm going to do that actually
it's going to take a bit of
experimentation but that's what I hope
to do in the next episode all with some
more detailing of course some old parts
of the city are still very undetailed
and of course add all kinds of new
things so yeah thank you guys for
watching and I hope to see you guys next
time
[Music]
you
[Music]